a little over 200 years ago a boy named
hakuji was born hakuji grew up in
poverty with a very sick father who he
was taken care of in order to pay for
his father's medicine hakuji
pickpocketed from people in town but was
caught many times in order to stop him
from stealing magistrate marked him with
tattoos to make him recognizable and
also threatened to cut off his arms next
time he gets caught stealing referring
to him as a demon child upon returning
home his neighbor told him that his
father having heard the news of his
arrest hung himself he left takuji a
letter telling him that he wanted his
son to live a full life and didn't want
to take medicine if it was earned by
dishonest means being marked with
criminal tattoos and having no home to
return to hakuji was eventually banished
from ido devastated by the loss of his
father and enraged at this society they
lived in where he couldn't afford his
father's medicine he picked fights with
people and beat them up one day after
nearly killing seven adult men in a
village he was approached by kaizo the
owner of a local dojo annoyed by the
man's cheerful demeanor hakuji
challenged him to a fight but was
defeated with ease kaizo then took him
in so he could nurse koyuki kaizo's
sickly daughter her mother her previous
caretaker drowned herself due to stress
and kaizo had to work handyman jobs to
keep them afloat so hakuji was tasked
with tending to her already accustomed
to caring for his father he had little
trouble though he found it awkward when
she burst into tears seemingly at random
one of those times unbeknownst to him he
had indirectly motivated her by telling
her that there will be the next year to
see a local fireworks show two years
later koyuki's health improved enough
that she could stand and do chores
hakuji continued training as kaizu's
pupil of the soryu style and the dojo
began to grow one day kaizu offered to
let hakuji take over the dojo and to
take his daughter koyuki as his wife
tohakuji's surprise and embarrassment he
agreed promising himself that he will
protect them both till the day he dies
at a festival koyuki told him of her
past asking if he was really okay with
the proposal to which he reaffirmed his
vows to her promising to protect her for
the rest of his life soon after hakuji
decided to go back to his hometown and
visit his father's grave proudly telling
his father that he got married but as
soon as he went back he realized that
something was wrong
a student from dojo ran towards akuji
informing him that the head of the rival
dojo poisoned the water koyuki and kaizo
were drinking and that the two died
shortly after drinking it having his
world turned upside down hakuji started
a fight with all 67 members of the rival
dojo he fought them all bare-handed and
killed every single one of them making
their corpses literally non-recognizable
after hearing this news the demon king
muzan kibutsuji went on to find hakuji
offering to make him an immortal demon
hakuji realizing that once again he has
lost everything accepts muzon's offer
and becomes the demon later known as
akaza after transforming into a demon
hakuji lost all of his human memories
completely forgetting about his father
kaizo and koyuki despite this as noted
by doma he refused to ever eat or harm
women due to his strength loyalty and
will to become stronger he became one of
muzon's favorites and he dispatched him
only for special missions such as
searching for the blue spider lily
a while later he was sent by muzon to
kill all of the demon slayers on the
infinity train akaza appears after
tantra and the demon slayers have
defeated enmu and rescued the passengers
noticing a downed tonjiro he immediately
rushes forward to kill him when rangoku
stops the attack and slices his arm in
half quickly healing the wound and
complementing his blade akasa is then
asked why he would attack an already
injured person to which he states he
simply wanted to rid him quickly before
talking to rengoku deeming him as at the
peak of his fighting spirit as a hashira
he attempts to persuade him to become a
demon he states that as a human he would
eventually become old and die whereas as
a demon he could continue to become more
powerful when rangoku repeatedly refuses
the offer and refutes his statements and
annoyed akasa declares he would instead
kill him and activates destructive death
compass needle akaza and rangoku battle
fiercely akaza is repeatedly cut but
instantly regenerates his wounds all
while taunting run goku by saying all
the hashers he had killed had never once
taken his offer to change the demon
launches in the air and hits rengoku
with air type knocking him back
temporarily though the attack is quickly
beaten knowing a battle at a distance
will be difficult the flame hashira
rushes forward and tries to attack up
close though all his swings are
deflected and dodged akaza starts to
make contact with his attacks severely
injuring the hashira oliver goku's sword
blows are futile with the demon's rapid
healing abilities and he starts to
become desperate with multiple flame
breathing attacks akaza suddenly backs
away allowing rengoku to catch his
breath only for tanjuro and inusuki to
see him bleeding profusely in contrast
to a completely fine and healed akasa
akasa once again taunts foreign goku for
his numerous injuries whereas he had
already healed instantly because of
being a demon and for fighting a losing
battle as a human
rangoku's body suddenly becomes engulfed
in fire declaring he will fulfill his
duty as a hashira to the demon's
confusion and wonder run goku decides he
would try to injure him as much as
possible even if it means dying and
speeds forward with flame breathing
esoteric art akasa is amazed at his
opponent's fighting spirit and decides
he must become a demon so they can
battle forever declaring he is the flame
hashira he uses flame breathing ninth
form rengoku and rushes forward akasa
responds with destructive death
annihilation type they hit each other
with ringoku slicing akasa's arm torso
and almost through his neck and akasa
driving his arm through ringoku's solar
plexus akaza desperately begs him to
become a demon knowing the wound he
inflicted is fatal and amazed at his
opponent's will to fight declares him
one of the few chosen strong ones
rengoku refuses once more remembering
his mother's promise to him to protect
the weak and drives his sword deeper
through his neck even catching his fist
when akaza tries to punch him with his
free hand shocking the demon the sun
begins to rise and akasa attempts to
flee but is held in place by rengoku
refusing to surrender tonjiro and
inusuki attempt to aid hashira inusuki
using fang1 pierce to attack the demon
akaza suddenly rips off his own arms
from goku's body and stomps the ground
creating a shockwave that knocks inusuki
away and gives him the chance to flee
tangero frantically gives chase and
hurls his nichiren blade at the upper
moon piercing his chest akaza hears
tonjeros cries calling him a coward for
retreating enraging him as he mutters to
himself that he was fleeing from the sun
not him deciding the battle over and
rangoku will soon die akaza flees to
safety in the forest akaza appears
before muzon and reports to him that he
could not find the blue spider lily
instead he took down one of the hashira
muzon retorts it was only one hashira
and declares his desire is for all to be
dead angered at his failure muzan takes
control of akasa cells and causes him to
bleed heavily the demon lord mocks him
for acting proud when three other demon
slayers were still alive and he could
have killed them as well ending his rant
by claiming even upper moon 3 was
brought to the ground
when dismissed by muzon for his failure
he takes notice of tanjuro's nearby
blade remembering how he called him a
coward he furiously smashed it to pieces
and declares he would spill his brains
the next time they meet
some time later akaza is suddenly
transported to the infinity castle by
nakime he is greeted by yoko and
hantengu but is disinterested in talking
to them he asked the biwa demon about
muzan's whereabouts and where is upper
moon 1 when he is cheerfully greeted by
doma annoyed by his attempts to have a
conversation with he irritably asks doma
to take his arm off him then violently
shatters his jaw when he doesn't an
unfazed doma continues trying to talk
and even believes the attack is simply a
sign of their friendship nakame answers
his question and states that upper moon
1 is the first to arrive who then
announces muzon's appearance muzon
voices his disappointment in guillotaro
and wonders aloud why the upper moons
are still around with no longer a proper
purpose akasa himself doesn't respond
knowing his recent failure yoko suddenly
states that he has new information for
their leader and doma unwittingly asks
if he can participate in a mission
causing akasa to angrily destroy his
superior's head for disobeying muzon's
orders suddenly his hand falls off and
kokushibo appears before him
reprimanding him for disrupting the
hierarchy a regenerated doma tries to
calm down upper moon 1 but he angrily
tells akaza if he wanted to take doma's
place and beat him he should do so in a
proper battle a silent akaza overhears
doma's statement that such a battle
would be fruitless since even the more
recently turned doma is far more
powerful than he is doma continues to
try defending akasa but kokushibu
directly asks him if he understood what
he declared akaza complies but quietly
threatens to kill him as well as
kokushibo disappears acasa rushes out of
the infinity castle ignoring doma's
attempts at another conversation a while
later inside the infinity castle tanjuro
and giu are rushing towards mouzon's
location suddenly a tremor appears
shaking both the demon slayers tantro
recognizes a familiar smell and the roof
above them breaks revealing upper rank 3
akaza okaza is surprised that a weakling
like tonjro is still alive and shouts
his name with tandro screaming his name
in return the fight between the three
begins a way for tanjuro to avenge the
death of the flame hashira
as akaza advances tandro dodges his
punch and uses the hinukami kagura on a
kaza and with considerable effort severs
the upper rank's arm asanjiro tries to
recover akaza attempts to behead tanjuro
with a back fist punch which tonjero
dodges and counters with the hinokami
kagura again managing to create a long
cut on a kaza's face akasa remembers
when goku's words about tantro not being
weak and accepts it as a fact deciding
to acknowledge him by activating his
technique development destructive death
compass needle and indicating the start
of the real battle after giu enters the
fight akasa was instantly impressed by
him as it has been 50 years since he ran
into someone as good as giu he uses his
destructive death disorder a flurry of
punches that produce giant shock waves
which giu negates with the water
breathing technique that he has created
akasa remarks that he had never seen
this technique used by the previous
water hashira he last fought while
tantro tries attacking him from behind
using the hinukamikagura akaza appears
from behind and attempts to backhand
chop but giu cuts off his attacking hand
as giu attacks the upper rank tantro
tries to rip akaza by using the
hinukamikagura flame dance on his legs
however he is countered by his
destructive death technique even though
tonjiro is able to block the technique
he is hit hard enough to spit blood
akasa continues to battle geyu and is
impressed by the hashira's swordsmanship
asking for his name kiu refuses and
akaza replies that he would ask again
and again and kicks him with his
destructive death launching him through
various walls to another side of the
castle akaza figures out the water
hashira's name after tonjiro shouts for
him when he is blasted away by akaza's
previous attack tonjiro and akaza attack
each other yet again akaza praises
tanjuro's improvement and claims that
rangoku did an amazing job pleased with
his death this enrages tonjiro and
promptsakaza to give his philosophy of
how he hates the weak and wishes they
were eliminated tondero retorts by
saying that even akaza was once a child
and that someone had helped him he
continues by stating the strong should
aid and protect the weak and he wouldn't
let a kaza do as he pleased any further
tonjero's words shake a kaza as he feels
restless and memories of kaizo appear
saying to him the same words mikasa
brushes it off and realizes it was but a
hallucination anchored he claims tonjiro
to be unpleasant and uses his blood
demon art and becomes much faster as
tandro attempts to dodge the demon
surprises tanjuro and manages to kick
him making him cough up more blood he
compares akaza's precision to that of a
magnetic compass and begins to think and
deduce using the demon's moves and words
tangero then dodges another kick by
akaza and attacks him with his breathing
akasa manages to avoid the technique
however a considerable portion of his
neck is sliced and he expresses
amazement asking tondro how he swung his
blade tondro attempts to use the
hinukamikagura dance but the sword is
clapped in a kaza's hand and he attempts
to break it tondro uses headbutts and
kicks trying to make a kaza loose in his
grip despite the demon not budging
luckily his hands got cut by giyu angry
about the deadly kick akaza gave him
previously guillo's a senses awaken and
a mark appears on his face he easily
dodges a shock wave punch and gives a
quick slice of his own akasa dodges but
the attack slices a small portion of his
neck the demon acknowledges the increase
in speed as guil surprises him with a
sudden water breathing fourth form
striking tide vertically slicing akasa's
right arm tantrum notices that akaza has
a matched yiu's speed and wonders how
akash's attacks are so accurate he
suddenly remembers words from akaza
explaining how he is able to sense
killing intent and how he cannot detect
people behind him if they have no
killing intent as the fight between giu
and akaza goes on tanjiro remembers the
time his father tonjero comodo explains
to him about correct breaths and
movements and about being able to see
the transparent world which one can
achieve if the mind becomes invisible he
demonstrates by killing a bear while
showing no killing intent tanjuro
manages to achieve this state for a
short moment in time when akaza attacks
him closing off other senses and
focusing on dodging akasa and giu are
battling fiercely trading blows to each
other the water hashira has used up all
his forms during the fight and akaza
proclaims that it will be the end of the
hashira amazed at how long he fought for
as giu is about to attack the demon's
fist akasa breaks giu's sword by using
the bell splitter technique and attempts
to punch through him but his arm is
severed by tandro who had managed to
enter the transparent world giyu takes
this moment to attack him but akaza uses
his strongest technique technique
development final form blue silver
chaotic afterglow giu tries to reduce it
with his water breathing but the attacks
were too random and powerful to
completely cancel out and he gets hit by
many shock waves despite managing to
dodge several blows meanwhile tandro was
able to see everything move slowly in
the transparent world akaza is unable to
notice that tantra was behind him and
giulio hopes he goes for the neck that
instant however tondro calls the demon
out and akaza turns to strike but
tonjero dodges akasa could not detect
his fighting spirit via the compass and
tantro manages to decapitate akaza with
his attack akaza was bewildered
wondering how tantro did not have any
fighting spirit comparing this feeling
to fighting against a plant he
acknowledges that tantros surpassed his
speed he realizes that the domain of
supremacy is nothing less than the
transparent world and a selfless state
he tries to attach his head back but
giul throws his broken sword piercing
the head separating it from the body his
head disintegrates but his body
continues to fight tangero dodges his
chops but is thrown aside by the demon's
kick he tried to get up and fight but
the stress and exhaustion of the fight
caused him to pass out geu protects
tangero with the water breathing slicing
the headless body in various regions but
the demon regenerates faster the two
begin to trade blows and although gio is
badly hurt he still focuses on
protecting tangero giving a cause of
vague memories of kaizo
as he advances he was stopped by the
teary-eyed spirit of his human self's
deceased fiance koyuki telling him to
stop
giulio continues to stand up despite
being burdened with the desire and goal
to not let his friends or family die in
front of him akasa was held by koyuki's
hand as his head continues to regenerate
akasa begins to remember why he wanted
to become strong and thinks back to the
time he was the demon child hakugi
from his father's death to meeting kaizu
and koyuki he remembers trying to find a
purpose and reason in life finding
someone to protect his memories of his
past suddenly come rushing back
during this tantro manages to wake up
and akaza's head has halfway recovered
the demon attempts to kill gilu with his
destructive death and tanjuro rushes to
stop him but his sword slips and he
punches a kaza causing him to question
his current deeds and begins to regret
sullying his master's precious style as
he prepares his technique tangero tries
to pull giu away but with a smile of
gratitude on his face akaza uses the
technique on himself mutilating and
pulverizing him and reducing many parts
of his body to bones akasa admits defeat
stating that tonjiro's technique was
magnificent and that he wants to go to
hell like a man
memories from the past overwhelm him as
he remembers his father and kaizo a
sudden image of muzon inside his head
forces him to start regenerating again
but he is stopped by his wife koyuki
finding peace at last akaza dies
reuniting with his loved ones
finally being free click on this video
where we explain the entire story of
kokushibo